when you say real do you mind defining i
know you just subtly defined it do you
mind explicitly defining what real is
because
the way that i'm thinking about this is
you just mentioned there's classical
mathematics let's just call it classical
mathematics and it leads to
contradictions like girdle mentioned and
one way of interpreting that is there
are limits to our knowledge there are
limits to mathematics another way is
that this is the wrong mathematics this
is not what is describing our universe
what's real is something else so girdle
you actually said that this is a blind
alley don't go down that alley rather
than this is the alley and here's our
limitations you're like no no no here's
constructive mathematics and you're
saying that this is real okay
help me understand what you mean when
you say real
just as a small tangent i think it's
unfair to godel to pretend that uh
this is what he thought he said good uh
actually believed in in this god of
mathematics that came to these
infinities and it was a big shock to him
when he came up with this proof and uh
so in some sense he
discovered something about uh the
mathematics that he believed and that
seemed to be real to him
uh that
he could not really get square and it's
also a thing that a lot of
mathematicians and physicists struggle
for instance i think it's part of what
motivates roger penrose
when he uh rejects the idea that
computers can be conscious because he
thinks
that human minds can do non-computable
mathematics in the same way as good to
him girdle has proven that computers
cannot do all of mathematics but human
minds can
for instance there
penrose has discovered these penrose
tilings these are uh there are tidings
which uh have an infinite variation
right there are infinities how can you
claim that there are no infinities but
you can uh you're only looking at a
function i think that uh basically has
an open-ended result it's similar to
the function that computes pi
pi is not just a value pi is a function
or a set of functions that give you for
instance if you translate this into the
decimal system digits it's an infinite
sequence of digits and you can get as
many digits as you can afford but you
can never have a function that relies on
having known the last digit of pi
where there is nothing where you feed in
pi and you get a result
you can only feed in a number of digits
of pi and you get a partial result
and uh
this result has the property that for
[Music]
it converges because the digits that you
get
denotes smaller and smaller fractions of
pi
and so the results tend to converge to
something but uh ultimately you don't
know the end of it
and uh so we have to be fair to girdle
to uh
he did not believe in computation as a
solution he's he was uh
strongly buried to this pre-constructive
mathematics and non-constructive
mathematics and he basically thought
that mathematics is somehow it has a big
problem in itself and it doesn't it was
just a problem of the formalization that
mathematicians have been using for a
long time
okay so uh let's get back to your
original question
yeah well uh sum it up again
what is real also we're talking about
this pi does the number pi exist
oh no like this sounds a bit odd but to
some people it's like well the
pythagorean theorem was discovered it
wasn't invented that the pythagorean
theorem for example
is true regardless of if humans are
around
okay then we can say does one exist did
we discover the number one or did it
exist and then we can similarly ask
does pi exist so what do you think does
pi exist what does it mean to
exist i think that uh pi is being
constructed and there are is a procedure
for this construction that we have
discovered and pi is as real as the
mandelbrot fractal
there is real in pretty much the same
sense right there's this pattern that is
uh self-contained
it is uh there whether you are looking
at it or not and it's a pattern that
cannot physically exist
uh at least not at an infinite
resolution because it's a pattern that
is defined with a procedure that gives
you more resolution the deeper you get
into it
and you will never know the last details
of the mandelbrot fractal and same way
you will never know the last details of
pi
right but there's a difference between
whether or not we can know it whether or
not it's computable and whether or not
it exists i think that pi in the sense
that you
say it's uh
defined with the last details does not
exist but a because
it cannot be implemented there can be no
system
built into the universe that is uh
expressing the last digits of pi
so
the last digits of pi do not exist in
the sense that they are real that they
are there somehow that are out there
and influence anything that they have a
causal influence on something else and
for something to exist
i think it is implemented in such a way
that it is a causal influence on other
things
and can be
consistently described with a model that
is describing that causal influence
and so do the integers exist
not all of them so and
right there's a large number n
yeah so
i would say that the integers are a
model they're a way of talking about
things that uh are real but
it's pointless to say that uh this model
exists because uh well it's a structure
that is being constructed the
implementation of the structure in your
own mind is being constructed the
realization of uh piano's arithmetic in
a computational system exists in a way
it's implemented to such a degree that
for a certain amount of time that system
can be stable enough to allow us to
perform computations with a certain
accuracy and at some point these
computers are going to fall apart
what i would say
exists is
one way of looking at this and it's
basically a thesis that i don't know how
to prove is that there is a causally
closed lowest layer that exists
and this is basically the mechanics of
the universe some kind of automaton that
produces everything that happens
and there seems to be something right
something seems to be real
and
um why is there something rather than
nothing i don't know why that is in some
sense it's the most obscene thing that
something exists rather than nothing
it's tremendous that's much more
confusing than everything else i'm aware
of
and
the easiest explanation for that is that
existence is the default so perhaps
everything that can exist
which means implemented without
contradictions
exists somehow and so you have the
superposition of all these computational
operators and some of these regions of
the resulting fractal contains s